hello everyone and welcome to one of the
best games from the 1959 candidates
tournament but before we started with
the game I would just like to announce
that the interview with vastly von
Schuch who rose from 1000 views to
17,000 views from yesterday so thank you
all for that I'm glad all of you enjoyed
the interview with Avant you can in case
any of you missed it I will put a link
in the description below so you can
check it out as it's really really
amazing so this game here we have a game
from round 4 of the 1959 candidates
tournament we have Paul Karras with the
white pieces against Tigran Petrosian
and their matchup in this tournament is
a really exciting one but I will say
something more about this after the game
so the official name of this game and
chess game chess Gamescom is Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon and it's really a
perfect name for this game that's why I
used it in the title as you do have the
crouching tiger and Tigran Petrosian
waiting for his opportunity to strike
and of course he goes for the dragon
Sicilian so I think it's really fitting
caris opens would be four we have c5 the
Sicilian defense on I have three Knight
to c6 and the d4c captors Knight
captures and g6 preparing the
accelerated dragon and we have c4 here
caris kind of announces that he wants to
go for the Marazzi bind setup pushing
the pawn to be 3 and this pawn to f3 and
to create a very nice pawn structure all
across the board Bishop to g7 we have
Bishop to e3 Knight to f6 and Knight to
c3 and here we have a move that is quite
that quite often happens in positions
like this Knight to g4 it seems like
black is offering a piece but of course
if you capture the knight then simply in
Knight captures on d4 as the Queen will
no longer be protecting the knight on d4
and this is a similar idea that happened
in the game one of my favorite games of
all time are our signature Medina versus
all like chair Nick off in 1962 only the
differences that nature Medina of didn't
place c4 he went for Bishop to c4 and
Bishop to b3 so we have Queen captures
and now Knight captures and
now the difference between the energy
Medina game is that he had a bishop on
b3 so he his Bishop was guarding the c2
square but now you can see that the
knight is threatening to jump to c2 to
fork the king and the rook and here you
have to bring the Queen back with Queen
to be one if you try and defend c2 with
something like Bishop to Bishop to d3
then black will have an excellent game
after d5 opening up a discovered attack
from the bishop to the Queen now you
definitely have to go back and now after
black captures only four he breaks your
they're nice pawn chain in the center
and white doesn't really have anything
here so after this night to d4 Queen to
d1 by Kerris and now comes Knight to e6
Queen to d2 again going for this
standard setup Queen d2 Bishop e3 to
threaten Bishop to h6 at some point to
exchange the powerful dragon d6 Bishop
to e2 and now Bishop to d7 Karis castles
petrosyan castles and rook a to see one
go to c6
we have rook F to D one and now Knight
to c5 we have f3 now protecting the e4
pawn and now a5 not allowing Karis to
push push away the night from c5 with b4
we have b3 and now comes Queen to b6 a
weird-lookin move
you know placing your Queen and b6 in
line of that Bishop on e3 but even if
something like Knight the d5 is played
and simply Bishop captures C captures
and Queen to b4 offering a trade of
Queens and this will be perfectly fine
you can't win a pawn here because after
all the exchanges are done the rook will
be a two points so you're not gonna have
too much fun playing this position
against Tigran Petrosian so after Queen
to b6 we have nice the b5 now and here
we have an extremely exciting moment in
the game where pitocin really shows what
a classy you know masterful guy he is
here Karis is threatening a 3 and B 4
simply attacking the pin piece and
winning winning the piece and it's very
interesting how Petrosyan takes
takes care of this he plays rook F to c8
and rook after c8 is is is very nice
because now if you continue with this
plan of a3 then simply Queen to d8 there
is no more
before idea because the knight is no
longer pinned and you've managed to
develop your rook the queen is now back
to the d8 but the rook is no longer
stranded on my fate so this was
petrosian's idea so after work after c8
we have a bishop to f1 making room for
Karis Queen to go to f2 to pile up on
that c5 Knight and now Queen back to the
8th again now the rook is developed and
the Queen can go back Queen to f2 and
now Queen to e8 we have Knight to c3 b6
and rook to c2 Queen to f8 now may be
preparing ideas like Bishop to h6 or
maybe maybe ideas like pushing the e
pawn so the Queen will be protecting the
d6 pawn Queen to d2 and now comes Bishop
to d7 Knight to d5
we have rook to b8 protecting the b6
born and now Bishop to g5 piling up on
that e backwards east 7 to 8 defending
and now comes Luke to e1 and here you
can never play a move like a 6 this
would be pretty terrible for black as
after Knight checks Bishop captures
Bishop captures after E 5 you're left
with a lot of weak dark squares around
your king and there's always this
problem of the backwards weak d6 pawn so
a player like carrots
I would definitely convert this
advantage into a win so after this rook
to e1 move rook the b7 by petrosyan we
have Queen to f2 and now comes Bishop to
c6 Queen to h4 we have f6 now Bishop has
to go back Bishop to e3 and only now he
6 because now there's no problem of that
Knight f6 idea since both the bishop and
the Queen are guarding the f6 pawn we
have knight back to c3 and now comes a
rook to d7
Bishop to d4 now f5 and here we have e
captures on f5
also a very interesting moment in the
game of what do you do here
do you play it captures on a5 or do you
play G captures on f5 if you go e
captures on f5 then Bishop captures on
g7 you can't capture with the Queen
because your route would be hanging on
e8 so after King captures now comes the
Queen to d4 check King to g8 and now
rook c2e2 doubling up on the e-file and
white is just better here but after this
it captures on f5 petrosyan decided to
go G captures on f5 we have rook to d2
and now Bishop captures rook captures
and now rook the g7 now Petrosyan you
will use the open G file to attack Karis
King King to h1 we have rook to g6
preparing ideas like like a small rook
lifts coming to g7 although you can to
do it immediately rook to d2 was played
but now rook to d8 of course you can't
go rogue to e7 immediately your d6 pawn
would not be defended anymore so rook to
d8
we have rook to d1 again pressuring that
d6 pawn and now rook to d7 would the
idea of Queen to d8 and also at some
point maybe rook coming to g7 Queen to
f2 we have Queen to d8 and now Quinta
III and here we have e 5 with ideas of
pushing f4 so here
caris pushes f4 himself so we have f 4e
for now and Knight to e2 and here we
have rook rook d2 g7 and if you look at
this position it's not that that white
is worse here or anything it's it's
simply that blacks position is so much
easier to play you have double crooks
and the G file the queen is ready to
jump to h4 you're ready to pull the H
pawn this bishop is eyeing that G to
pawn nicely x-ray get over the pond but
always a knight to d3 will always be an
idea if you capture the night with your
bishop at some point then you recapture
with this point your bishop comes alive
so black ideas that black might use in
this game are all are all fairly clear
and it's very hard to defend the passive
position like this with white so nice
the d4
Petrosyan pushed efore so he weakened
the d4 square
caris immediately takes advantage of
this Bishop to d7 and now comes a three
we have Queen to eight and king to g1
Kara's doesn't like the idea that after
patrols in plays Knight to the three and
this pawn recaptures that this this Jeep
on will be pinned due to the Queen being
on a8 so he will be unable to push g3 we
have h5 and now here you really have to
find a plan for black you can Karis
played rook to be one if you decide to
play something like b4 then indeed you
get this night these remove and after
Bishop captures pawn captures now you
have this nice to have to remove and
although it's perfectly fine for white
it's it's a very very hard position to
play so Karis doesn't go for this he
goes for rook to be one and now h4 yeah
we have look b2 b2 now both rocks are on
the second rank regarding that g2 pawn
and here we have rook to g4 if you play
something like pawn to h3 then Karis can
simply capture it Queen captures and
there's really nothing but I can do to
take advantage of this rock h7 Queen
simply moves and you're not breaking
through so after this rugby to be to
petrosyan has a different idea rook to
g4 he will now still grab more space and
also maybe pile up on this week f4 pawn
so rook to f2 guarding the f2 pawn and
now comes Queen to d8 b4 and now here
you can do a couple of things and it's a
very nice position for you to actually
check out maybe even pause the video and
try to find the Patronus move as it's
it's it's really a towel move not a
petrosyan move if you play something
like a knight to d3 here after Bishop
captures pawn captures Queen can simply
capture and white is perfectly fine here
there's no real way for black to
continue this attack the double rooks on
the second rank are guarding this pawn
nicely the knight can always come to f3
and then g5 to block the rooks so
so it's not a very good idea for black
so after this before a move Petrosyan
actually plays at Alamo he plays rook to
g3 and what do you do here now obviously
you can capture the rook or you can move
the Queen if you move the Queen then you
know first you have to check out where
do you put the Queen then this rook can
move but if you if you're gonna capture
it is better to capture it immediately
which which is what Cara's did and it's
it's not really that this is a mistake
it just gives Petrosyan a lot of
attacking chances so H capture Sanji 3 H
capture some g3 and now this is a
classical moment after one player
sacrificed some material where you will
have that maybe you will have one moment
to defend properly and here you have to
decide how to defend properly so how
would you defend in this position H
captors and g3 was played Petrosyan is
threatening to capture your rook on f2
he's threatening to play Queen to h4
with ideas of Queen to h2 checkmate so
how would you defend one idea which
Karis missed in the game was rook to f3
you just want to look so you don't want
to be up too much material if you're you
know probably getting checkmate it so
after rook to f3 black definitely
doesn't want to capture Queen to h4
threatening Queen to H - but now Bishop
to e2 making room for the King to escape
so after the King moves to f1 the Queen
can come to help out with the defense
with Queen to g1 and after each captors
on f3 Knight captures an f3 attacking
the Queen also guarding the h2 square so
Quinta retreat and now B captures on c5
but this is this is the idea
Charis Charis might have considered this
but then you have to see that if you
capture the night you lose the game
actually because of rope to h7
threatening checkmate and opening up a
discovered attack from the Queen to rook
on b2 so in this extremely complicated
position
Karis played rook f2 d2 and now now he
will have some problems here Petros and
immediately played Queen to h4 the
threat of course is Queen 2h - checkmate
and here he played Bishop 2
now comes rock 2h7 and now there is only
one move that will that will allow you
to defend this position with white but
Karis missed that move as well the move
Karis missed was Bishop to h5 first you
have to give up the bishop and not just
give up the bishop
but you have to free the e2 square for
your king so after you give it up the
rook captures now King to f1 and you can
escape with the king but Karis missed
this and that rook to h7 he played King
to f1 immediately what's the idea that
everything is perfectly fine if Queen to
h1 then comes Queen the g1 defending and
White is perfectly fine the night is
still attacked and on c5 so you can
always capture it but here Petrosyan
actually has the checkmate in five moves
so it's a perfect position for you to
pause it you know try to try to find the
Trojans move and it's quite beautiful
because he already sacrificed one work
for the attack and now comes the
punchline
so do pause it do try to find the
Trojans move I will give it a couple of
seconds as always for those of you who
were able to solve this it's you know a
beautiful move you're an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here petrosyan
played Queen captures on f4 this comes
with Czech and the idea is really simple
but also you know the position is so
elegant that even a simple idea like
this is really beautiful
the idea is simple because you only have
to get rid of the Queen you have to
deflect the Queen from defending the g1
squared so now if you capture the Queen
simply rook to h1 is the immediate
checkmate as the Queen can no longer
block at what Queens you want and this
bishop is preventing the King from
coming to e2 and if you don't capture
the Queen well then you really don't
have any moves simply you move the King
now black doesn't even have to capture
the Queen he can simply play worked h1
check and you have to block this either
by the bishop and then you're
immediately getting checkmate it or you
can give up first the Queen and then the
bishop and then it's Queen captures on
f1 with checkmate so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I really
think the title is fitting Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon
you know if there wasn't for the towel
game against miss love that one the
brilliancy prize you know there are so
many games that could that were probably
candidates for the brilliancy prize but
you know you can't you can't out tall
tall so yeah after this Queen captures
on a four carries resigned the game and
yeah
before I forget I couldn't find a photo
of Petros I'm playing against Carris in
this tournament but I did find a nice
photo of them here it is let me just
enlarge it a bit sorry about that yeah
there we go this is a game from 1963 it
was played in the Piatigorsky Cup also
you can see
Petrosyan here with the black pieces and
carrots with the white pieces there you
know having a good laugh before their
game so quite a nice photo add there
will be a link in the description below
if you want to use that for for
something and for those of you who are
maybe new to the 1959 candidates
tournament or new to this channel here
are the final standings for this
tournament so as you can see pal won it
then we have carrots in second place
patrols and in third and then the rest
of the players I'm sure you already know
know that but it's it's very interesting
that
Petrosyan is the only player who had a
positive score against Paul Carey's in
this tournament as aside from this game
that petrosyan won all the other three
games were drawn and it's very
interesting that Karras and petrosyan
played some 35 games throughout their
life and the result at the end is a draw
because Petrosyan won three games Karras
won three games and the other how many
29 games were drawn so definitely you
know a great rivalry and but in this
tournament the Troezen had the upper
hand he had the only positive score
against Carris but in the end Karras won
second place in Petrosyan third so yeah
like I said I do hope you enjoyed it I
do hope you enjoyed a photo of the two
of them and I would like I would like to
thank Locutus the Borg Vladimir Kozyrev
and Amedeo sick for a conversion to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and I
see you soon with another game from the
1959 candidates tournament season